hey everyone and welcome to console crew
this week we're talking about the fact
that the playstation vita lives
it's the switch's fourth anniversary and
we'll be talking about some game called
old rings something i don't know it'll
come back to me
joining me as always we've got xbox
expert jordan remain
yo and playstation pro that's what he's
saying
i doubt you could even imagine it
leaking on like a postage stamp size
video
with blurry textures and artifacting
maybe workshop that one time yeah using
it again
that's true yeah of course we're gonna
be talking about the elden ring leaks
we're not gonna show him
because that sucks it would make
miyazaki sad
and if anyone makes miyazaki sad i will
kill them
wow okay oh my god i hope this doesn't
get used in a trial
okay let's kick off with eldon ring um
and the fact is
leaks suck for everyone
jordan what happened you know leaks are
the way i phrased that video like you
did it i was like
why did you lick this look i just wanted
tam to be happy and to see what elden
ring looked like and so i was like oh
you know maybe like this
nothing like this but yeah eldon ring
got into the news recently because
a few uh reputable sources we're hinting
at the fact that maybe we're gonna get a
microsoft
xbox event this well yeah this month in
march
later maybe march 23rd nothing really
confirmed no one knows
and then and the xbox except just came
on i was like no this
we're not going to show elden ring off
at any
upcoming event we have stuff in the
works nothing on
par with like an announcement for eldon
ring
which made people sad and then kind of
to like
make people feel even worse following
that someone leaked
a very very poor recording of what looks
to be
a gameplay reveal trailer for
eldon ring i mean it looks like a dark
souls game in
an open world so i'm inclined to believe
that it's alden
it's the bandai na uh bandai namco
ee watermark for me um it's very clear
where that came from
probably someone just recorded it
off-screen to look cool and sent it to
his friends who sent it to more friends
and that's how it spiraled
um this is like so unfortunate and time
i'm sure you could speak to this is like
is this the way you wanted to see eldon
ring
is the way that we wanted to find out
about eldon ring is because people were
leaking like
oh um miyazaki and george are martin are
working on something
and it oh yeah and i remember the leak
at the time it was like it has horses in
it
yeah no this is not how most people want
to see it mainly because
often like as is the case here you get a
very
compromised look at what it is like
there's been
efforts to and there is a video of it i
won't we won't link it or anything or
someone has scaled it up to 720p and you
can get a really crisp
version of those videos or that video
it's like a minute or two long
and yeah it you can make out that it
looks like a game that from software
would make but the audio is rubbish this
the kind of there's no details you can
see you can make out this dragon but you
can't really see that there's a dragon
on it
i think the issue that the bigger issue
is
it's probably not representative of what
eldon ring currently looks like
um often when these leaks happen it's
like a version from
a little while ago and you know other
things have
other development cycles have come to
pass and there's been
changes to it and the thing that we're
looking at apparently is quite old
um and perhaps at this point doesn't
look like
what you know elder ring looks like in
from software's
offices there could be ideas in there
that are
who knows have been ditched or maybe on
aren't like you know
as fleshed out as we may think it is but
it all around it creates unrealistic
expectations
and opinions of the game and it also
kind of
it reduces the creative kind of impact
and control that the developers have
uh obviously people are going to say
this is just marketing so what you're
complaining about yeah it is marketing
that's true 100 but marketing also
serves a purpose like
i wanted to be hyped about this um and
the way i got hyped about it would would
have been through a trailer which yeah
is marketing but
all the trailers that hot you hold dear
for games that you hold in all the
trailers that you were quite excited
about
for games that's marking like and
there's also a kind of that
that um line of thought where it's like
well they should have released something
earlier
and it's clearly ready to be shown so
why didn't they just release it which is
just
i i it's just a moronic like line of
thinking like
that's that's ridiculous and a stupid
thing to say like
it just it doesn't you're not entitled
to a trailer
you're not entitled to anything and
that's the thing it's like
you're not getting the best first look
like you said it's compromised and it's
really bad quality and so what are you
getting from that other than the fact
that you can say oh i've seen what eldon
ring
looks like right we've seen this it
happens time and time again like every
time a huge leak happens
the tweets from developers are always
just like
every time something like like morale
studios just plummets
and you can you can see why because
people have been pouring their heart and
soul into this for so long
and they want to show you it to be
representative of what you'll actually
play or at least as near to
representative and so
it sucks and it's like i'm hyped about
elden ring like
tam god i know your heights welding ring
but it's like this ain't it
yeah this is not how we want to see it
worse
the issue you have now is like
developers that that has leaked
developers
have clear usually and publishers have a
roadmap for when they want to start
talking about things
and most developers won't break that
japanese developers even less likely to
break that road map
so right now from software is in a
position where they can't address
all the criticism or all the takes that
people are having about it
i've seen stuff like oh it looks like
they're just focusing on magic and it's
gonna be op
and oh it just looks like another souls
game and all that that you know that
area doesn't look good this looks a bit
rough
from software can't say anything about
that like they're not they're not in a
position to do that and
and and like the same is for the
publisher which is a shame they can't
come out and go like actually it doesn't
work like that anymore here's how here's
what you're missing
here's what you're not seeing in that
weird magic that turns into a sword
actually we've done three passes and
this looks way different now it looks
amazing on the screen
um or it looks like we've removed this
thing they can't address any of that and
they just have to kind of sit there and
take it and that happens with
all leaks and that's just a shame like
it's
that sucks there's no real benefit to
having this postage stamp sized
gross looking video footage of it
available other than like lucy said
you can say you've seen it but what have
you seen you've seen an old bit of work
for a game that you should have been
excited about but now like
i'm still excited about it but i would
have loved to have had a big
trailer that we could like dissect and
do features on and maybe even reach out
to
from software and talk about and kind of
pull apart but we don't have that now
we've got this
shite trailer and now when you when you
google it you search
all the ring you just get loads of
videos of people going
reacting to trailer and it's just like
no one wants to see that
man this week marked the fourth
anniversary of the nintendo switch
and breath of the wild um which means
that obviously this is the time that i'm
actually gonna try and get into breath
of the wild
because i shamefully dropped off it uh
the first time i tried to play
back in 2017 but it's been four years of
the switch
a lot of incredible games honestly like
i missed traveling because that was beat
that would be
primarily when i would play my switch
most because it was just this perfect
on-the-go console but i'm finally now in
the groove i'm playing a lot more of it
at home
but it's got me thinking because it's
right there next to my xbox one
playstation
is it time for that bad boy to get
upgraded boys do we think it's time
for the switch pro and what would it
what would you like your switch pro
to have i think it is time for a switch
pro um
i don't know i don't think it's
essential kind of like nintendo has
proved that he can make the most of
hardware that isn't like you know overly
powerful or like on on the same level as
other their console um platforms and
manufacturers
but i think it would be nice to to have
a high-end version of it we've got a
switch light it would just be good to
kind of round it out and have this kind
of
hey if you play on this version of the
console you'll get
you know 4k graphics or whatever it may
be um
i would love to see that happen and i
think it would be a good time to also
maybe
put an end to the joy-con drift and
kind of refresh the kind of uh the
controller for that console and
miracles tam and possibilities i mean
like
it is a good opportunity i would love to
do that there's so many games that i
would love like i'm also playing breath
of the wild now
for the first time um not for the first
time i tried many times before but i got
distracted
um and like i each time like it looks
nice but i'm just like i'd love it to
see
every now and then there's a hitch and
i'm like yeah in in particular
like heavy um you know if you especially
if you use bombs or if there's a lot of
water or something
um it's it definitely hitches
and it does you play breath of the wild
the way max plays breath of the wild
oh yeah yeah it's it's it's a lot like
and and
it doesn't happen often enough to ruin
the experience but i would love to have
a high-end
uh high-end version of uh the switch
that i can see
like more vibrancy and and there's less
of those starters now and then
most other games that i play on there
are absolutely fine like
loads of hades no issues there played
loads of like
even dark souls i've played on there and
it's it's great um
but yeah i don't think it's necessary
but i think it would be a good option
especially because like
now that now that i have started playing
on
on my tv i'd like it to perform a bit
better so that when
hopefully fingers crossed the world does
return to normal i can have like a
dedicated
um high-end switch set up at home and
then have
my normal switch which throw in my bag
and just take it around i say it'd be
nice to have a little more improvements
on it like i
i really want an ethernet port on the
switch like i know you can buy that
little
doohickey add-on to add an ethernet port
to it
but i don't want to add anything to my
console when i'm playing it on the go
now with games like fortnite and apex
legends coming to it in splatoon 3 on
the way i'm like just a way to ensure
that my switch can like
consistently remain online and i don't
have to play these
shooters over wi-fi would be glorious
well that's the thing i was gonna bring
up is that you know we've got more and
more third-party
um developers porting things over to the
switch apex legends is coming next week
but you know when things when these more
graphically intense games
do get poured over you do have to
compromise what they look like
for portability and so that's why i
would love to see
a bit more you know i'm not expecting
ps5 series x graphics on a switch but it
definitely
a little boost in the power would be
great i think as well for when the world
goes back to normal
battery life please
so i can play silk song forever when it
comes out on twitch
uh final fantasy 12 absolutely
rips through that battery
so i would i would love to see that or i
would love to see some element of like
just a better quick charge you know yeah
i think there's there's also like last
gen games that are available
on the switch that are there but you're
like
it's it's a novelty because they they
they like have taken a hit like the
witcher 3.
i was gonna say literally i was looking
at my switch in the day and i was like
why did i buy
the witcher 3 on this it runs on there
for sure but yeah you look at it and
you're like
oh yeah you can see how they got this to
run and i'm not i'm kind of like
dissuaded from
playing it whereas an upgraded more
powerful one
having like a really like on the level
of a playstation 4
version of the witcher on the switch on
a switch would be amazing
um and that goes for like a bunch of
other games like overwatch and
epics and you know do you think a more
powerful
switch would be like the opposite of the
light
it would be always the chunk chunk like
yeah it would just be a traditional
console at that point just always hooked
to your tv and you could never
take it into handheld no i don't think
they would compromise on that
i think that's the one thing yeah i
think like we're at a stage where
mobile or you know handheld
hardware um through like amd and video
that kind of stuff
it's it's in a position where they can
have that power bump it's just a matter
of whether nintendo wants to do it or
not at this stage
we've seen some devices that are small
and incredibly powerful
so get on it but we're not done
with handhelds no because there is one
fabled handheld
that is hanging on for dear life
how can you kill what's already dead
you can't that's the answer but it's
getting a new game damn
the vita lives the unkillable vr lives
um it's getting a brand new game in 2021
this the year of our lord hirotaka
miyazaki
um avita was discontinued in 2019 but
now there is
a game coming to it scourge bringer
which
um has been out for a while right if i
remember correctly um
yeah so that is if you still have your
vita and you want to play a new game on
it scotchbringer is coming so there
hasn't been a physical release for the
vita since
march 2019 um but every now and then
it does get like a small title upgrade
or like a new release
so at least you've very kindly listed
out gods of alma guest
habroxia too pachypatchy on a roll so it
gets some games that literally no one
cares about
i'm about to say i was waiting for you
to mention something that i had heard of
yeah like
what is this is he casting a spell
uh yeah so there's games that come out
usually low profile games
there are probably people out there who
care about gods of alma guest because
the internet is wild and wacky
i'll get some gods of alma guest fans
sending me a death threat tomorrow
but yeah it's the 10th anniversary of
the vita in japan this year
and it's nice to see that it's still
kicking the vita still an amazing
handheld i i i've got mine i keep it
ready
i play um metal gear on it now and then
it's just full of
dragon grandpa videos videos uh games
uh that's danganronpa for the weebs out
there
um and yeah so i guess the question here
is like
do you see a future in playstation
handhelds
uh for me i think they've taken all that
energy and just gone
we're vr now uh yeah friendship ended
with handheld
vr is my new best friend uh so
i i personally don't see it but i would
love a vita too
it would be cool but like nintendo was
dominating that game with a 3ds and now
i think just with
the switch it's just that's their space
and i don't think
xbox or playstation no matter what they
do can try to
carve a spot for them in that space i
don't think they'll come out with a new
console
however i do think they will um put more
resources into
uh on the xbox side xcloud and
playstation uh remote play
uh which i've been i've been messing
around with which is the stupidest thing
because
my bed is there my tv is there it's like
it's not like i'm going anywhere
but um i have like my tablet and i
tried out xcloud and uh remote play on
it and both of them worked really really
well
and so i was like okay i could see this
working if
you know like my consoles are here and
i'm back you know if i am ever traveling
anywhere
i don't know where but you know i could
i could just like
remote in and that would be enough for
me
couldn't play it on a plane or anything
obviously but then
i just i just don't think they're going
to make i don't think they're going to
do it
it's like you said vr is where it's at
for them and
xbox isn't doing it nintendo is sure as
hell not going to
do it but yeah you can use labo
you can use libo
i want you to name a single time you use
labo lucy
i paused zelda the other day and it was
like you used tycon vr
i was like what the [ __ ] i made the
fishing rod
in labo and it was very fun uh except it
was like don't lie to me lucy
i've got videos of it it was like
weirdly well because i love i love like
crafts and
so i mean look at me behind me lucy
loves crafts and
that's my there we are that's my studio
ghibli cross stitch i'm doing i'm a
crafty girl
i like labo i just i have nowhere in my
place
to put it however if they you know
did more labo i'd like it dude i
wouldn't buy it but i'd like it
i'd like it i wouldn't buy it i would
admire it from afar that's the classic
that's some good cardboard that is the
classic gamer we want this thing
we want this remastered all right we've
released it i'm buying that are you
crazy
i'm not paying 60 dollars for this i
just want you to waste your money yeah
i i've decided to change my mind i think
there's going to be a psv or two because
you know manifest what you want in the
world
in 2021 and i want a via too so
um vr2 lives
let's let's get it going vita 2
or switch pro if either of them ever
going to exist
what would you like to see let us know
in the comments below jordan tam
thank you so much for joining me and
thank you all for watching we're really
enjoying being back and it's really nice
to read the comments so people are like
we're glad that you're back so thank you
for those
um we'll be back again next friday with
another episode of console crew see you
then
you